Le voilà Maitre.
-Enfin,
j'attendais ce jour depuis si longtemps.
Grâce à ce sceptre maléfique
forgé par les anciens,
je vais plonger le monde des humains
dans les ténèbres
et le chaos!
(rire maléfique).
Vous rigolez pas?
-Euh si.
Non, vous rigolez pas là.
Non, mais, bon je vous cache pas
que je suis un peu déçu
parce que vous allez abattre
les ténèbres et le chaos, c'est ça?
Euh oui.
Bah ça par exemple
ça m'arrange pas du tout
parce que qui dit ténèbres
dit brouillard,
qui dit brouillard
dit humidité,
qui dit humidité
dit infiltration,
enfin bref, on va encore
se peler les miches.
Les humains se prosterneront,
on sera tout puissant!
Les humains ils allumeront des torches,
qu'est-ce qu'ils en ont à foutre
ils passent la moitié du temps enfermés
de toute façon.
Et les monstres?
Ah, on n'y avait pas pensé aux monstres?
Ca fait bien flipper ça.
Et puis c'est pas les torches
qui vont les arrêter.
Ca c'est sûr, même nous
on n'arrive pas à les arrêter.
Non mais pour le dressage
on est sur une piste là.
Ah mais c'est ça ce que faisait Philippe ce matin!
-C'est ça!
D'accord.
Et ben il est mort.
Et qu'est-ce qu'on fait alors,
on fait de la glace?
C'est une super idée ça la glace!
-Je viens d'y penser, c'est une connerie
Parce que, c'est un sceptre de ténèbres,
pas un sceptre de glace.
C'est le genre de truc où vous testez un pouvoir
qui était pas prévu à la base,
ça vous fait un pet foireux.
-Ok j'ai compris.
Vous êtes pas capable de régner
sur un monde de glace.
Evidemment que je suis capable.
C'est pas grave,
c'est pas une honte hein.
Je suis capable de le faire!
Me cherchez pas.
Ok, on y va.
-Ok, je suis prêt.
Peut-être y'a une formule à dire.
On pourrait peut-être
fermer sa gueulesurtout?
Mais pourquoi j'écoute un sbire!
Je mets enfin la main sur le truc
qui va me permettre de régner
et Monsieur veut une glace!
-Pas besoin d'objet magique
Non euh, vous
ce qui vous caractérise c'est le ...
Le courage
-Le courage, voilà.
Et c'est moi qui commande.
-Et puis c'est vous qui commandez.
Ça va être un massacre.
-Ça va être un massacre.
On y va maintenant!
-On y va maintenant!
Et vous venez avec moi!
-Euh, ok.
A nous deux, humains!
Aaah!
Eh Fifi, braque à gauche,
non l'autre côté, aah!
Ça va marcher cette fois!